i do not think that democracy is about
governments having unlimited
uncontrolled and uncontrollable powers
national stems
ever since the news broke the u.s has
been spying on europe meps have been
livid but now they're taking action an
inquiry will be launched look into
allegations and will present its
findings by the end of the year at the
plenary
it's the end of the road for this ship
many like it and are broken up for
recycling on beaches in india pakistan
and bangladesh parliament's environment
committee will vote to push ahead with
controversial plans that will allow
toxic old ships to be recycled outside
of the eu
so long as ship owners adhere to strict
environmental requirements at eu
approved facilities this is one of the
worst environmental catastrophes because
old ships contain really toxic materials
many of them today are banned and when
they are scrapped on a beach all this
very hazardous waste leaks into the
water
and damages both workers and environment
under polling conditions and hopefully
this will now come to an end
controversy over the tobacco products
directive as the environment committee
votes to regulate the online sale of
electronic cigarettes by classifying
them as medicinal meaning it would be
harder for would-be smokers to get their
hands on them a win for the industry
said